so of course we seen you most recently
in Great Expectations now how did you
enjoy bringing that role to the life on
the big screen really loved it actually
I'm I'm I loved the novel and it can be
slightly intimidating or although have
you pressure yourself when you know that
you're taking on such an iconic
character but but once you kind of get
on set it's such a fun game like acting
out someone that you know in your kids
and you'd kind of you want to be the
characters that you read in books and so
it's like it's great to actually be able
to do that as an adult what was your
approach to playing the vids part
because obviously there have been a
number of iterations of great
expectations on the big and small screen
haven't there yeah what David Nicholls
script was and I pick one I think quite
specific in how he wrote Estella which
is the kind of character that I sort of
read from the book and I'm so I loved
his script and I think it's just you've
got to find aspects about characteristic
that you like or relate to and so just
kind of going back through the novel and
go and seeing the bits of a seller that
you you kind of that interest you and
trying to try to put those across and I
think of everyone else you work with a
fantastic British cast and only one of
him young guy Jeremy Irvin now how easy
or difficult was it to be nasty to him
could you have to be quite nasty to Pitt
don't it yeah I couldn't think of it's
been nasty thing she's just like you
know she's just damaged and she wants to
know when when she called but no I mean
it's odd but that new you know we kind
of whenever they were the scenes that
were nasty to each other we kind of
shouting at each other so he's fine so
it was good yeah who else did you enjoy
acting along sighs it was amazing
working with Helena because she's
amazing she still imaged I love her as
an actor ever since when ever since
being younger and and so too it's quite
it's quite exciting every day and to
just be able to watch her and watch how
she gives a different performance each
tank and it's all very believable and
still and I was it's great when you're
working with someone and they give you
so much when you're when when it's sort
of your close up and she really does and
it's like yeah it's it is great to feel
like you're learning from someone I
think what can we see from you next and
I've just finished season three of The
Borgias and yes so that should be that
should be out in a few months I think
what can fans expect from that it's
people are following it very hotly on
those yeah oh yeah I think I think you
visit it's very much more of more of the
Borgias and I think there's this year
desert one all that all the bits of
intimacy that people were people have
been rooting for come to fruition
you